I'm gay
I've known for a while now and I wanted
you to know I even have a boyfriend
Etienne who lives in Canada it was
honestly I can't imagine that being
happening with anyone else first of all
I'm so glad that the writers included
some sort of special storyline for Ozzy
and I'm glad that they made it with
Deborah Joe or with Kitty
oh sweet boy get in here
you just made me feel really special
it was definitely a RV because a lot of
the scenes I had to do were live and
also it was an important uh week episode
for my character so it was really sweet
it was also really sweet to see those OG
That 70s Show cast members return what
was that moment like for you uh it was
just it was I was in awe the whole week
even though Wilmer who plays back wasn't
in the pilot so he did come to watch
them watch the show and support his
fellow cast names and so it was
interesting and really heartwarming to
see all of them back the OG people are
so talented
six seconds
damn Jackie will you just give me a
minute to enjoy this is there one cast
member in particular that maybe you were
the most star-struck by Mila was you
know going from door to door just kind
of checking in on everyone yeah I mean
she's just so sweet both everyone and
they
they're so humble and down to earth and
they treat everyone as equal that 90s
show has been renewed for season two
I think we all thought it would get a
second season but we just because That
70s Show was such an iconic show and you
know I feel like there was a lot of
pressure we definitely thought season
two was gonna come but we just didn't
know that it was going to be 16 episodes
tell me for season two what would you
love to see happen with Aussie storyline
I would like Beyonce go to Canada and
see and meet at the end because that can
come out over there with to you guys I
became a fan of yours when I saw Barb
and star go to Vista Del Mar
[Music]
for you to spend some time with a comedy
Legend like Kristen what was that
experience like for you I never even
thought it was going to be such a big
movie she would just do these things
that were not even written in the script
and I was just like wow like that's
really cool so it actually inspired me
to do them in problem
so not everything you see in the movie
The Final Cut is all in the description
box